there's no challenge to Happy Valley
breakfasts at a hotel outside Dublin and
these small business owners are being
taught how to fill out piles of customs
papers if brexit means a border going up
across Ireland they'll have to and it's
an expense many can barely afford this
is what people mean when they say the
Irish economy could suffer because of
brexit do businesses know do you know
what the British government's plan is I
don't I don't
a widely commentator says the start is
whole process don't watch the inches
watch the miles so if you're trying I
think if you're trying to follow brexit
step-by-step I'll be incredibly
frustrating because it's not a logic
that most people are familiar with ever
since he became Prime Minister Boris
Johnson has said the UK will leave the
EU before November in his letter to the
European Union he also insists a new
deal can and must be found to free his
country from being stuck in a customs
union because it's been rejected by the
British Parliament but neither here nor
in Brussels today believe him we have no
idea
ultimately the latter didn't go into
much detail but he keeps referring once
again to the so called alternative
arrangements the problem with these
alternative arrangements is they don't
exist none have been given to us as an
example in operation anywhere in the
world
there haven't been laid out properly so
that's why we really do need the box off
as that an insurance policy the sharp
end of all this is in Irish border towns
like Dundalk
we're free movements in and out of the
UK is crucial to their livelihoods
there is no overstating the anger they
hold towards the British government but
the one thing that we've learnt about
Irish history over the generations has
been that when Britain gets bored and
wonders are from the topic problems
arise and then it's only when there is a
problem that we can open that we can
bring them back into the looking at it
instead of looking at it in the camp
situation weather isn't a security or
anything else underlying the issue so
imagine a scenario in which this
motorway crossing the border has customs
posts and queues of traffic with all the
contingent security risks to the piece
it might not be far away the dread fear
in Ireland is that any
physical manifestation of a border could
lead to dissident Republicans attacking
not only British but Irish customs
officials Britain says it's just scare
mongering there will never be a border
on the island of Ireland but in his
letter to the European Union Boris
Johnson cannot say how he could
guarantee is in the center of Don Dorcas
sculpture was erected after former US
President Clinton helped finalize the
Good Friday peace deal and addressed a
hundred thousand people in celebration
the sculpture is called dialogue and
celebrates the art of compromise how
times have changed
Lawrence Lee al Jazeera on the Irish
border